so so my goal is to talk about a few
computational models that I see being
used regularly in practice first let me
tell you what I'm not going to tell you
so there's no new results or fancy lower
bounds or anything here my goal is
really to bring your attention to a
couple of computational models that I
see that work well in practice that seem
to be liked by practitioners in the in
the world in their type of models that
I'm going to talk about there's quite a
lot of nice upper bounds not many lower
bounds and the gap between the upper
bounds lower bounds and what tends to
get used in practice is quite large and
I think for any one of these topics
upper bounds or lower bounds or practice
there are very smart people who can tell
you lots of details about them and if
you want to hear about all three of them
in the same talk you're probably stuck
with me so that's so in large data
analysis there are two what I'd consider
milestones one is the first one is
something that most people here are very
familiar with the work of a lone
matthias legatee which is which happened
about 20 years ago this is the frequency
moments problem for I'm assuming
everyone knows what frequency moments
are so ok so let's do it you are given a
stream of elements from some universe
and every element appears a certain
number of times called its frequency the
first freak the frequency moment the
Kate frequency moment says you take
these frequencies raise them to the gate
power for each element some them over
all the elements right so if you do it
for k equals 1 obviously you get the
number of elements you add up all the
frequencies raised to the power 1 you
get the number of elements frequencies
raise to 0 is an interesting one because
that is considered the distinct element
problems you'd count how many distinct
elements there are in the stream that's
a very interesting problem in its own
right with a lot of practical
applications as well the most
interesting i think the surprising
factor here was k equals 2 which
corresponds to
some very natural questions and
databases about joint sizes and other
things what alone madison secretary did
was to give a surprisingly low space one
pass streaming algorithm for this
problem they gave a log m space where m
is the size of the universe here
typically we tend to think of the size
of the universe is polynomial in the
length of the stream so you know this
are about the same equally amazingly in
the same paper they also gave a lower
bound for kate frequency moment for
which applies when k is at least six i
think so this has since been improved we
now know pretty much the optimal bond
Tooting each n to the 1 minus 1 over k
the lower bounds are shown from a
reduction from set disjoint pneus the
multi-party number in handset disjoint
us that we heard about earlier today so
there alone which is integrity showed a
polynomial load one so there is a nice
gap between the second and the
high-frequency woman's and this paper
turned out to at least for theorists
crystallized the problem of data stream
algorithms and the whole area came about
about 10 years later Jeff Dean and
Sanjay gamma wat who who are at Google
published this very nice paper and I
think the operating systems conference
Oh SDI what they introduced was a
programming abstraction right it's not a
new computational model or anything it's
really a programming abstraction and
people in databases and systems often
have a criticism they say that we've had
this for 20 years or 30 years or
whatever but what what Dean gabala did
was to make it actually very very easy
to use they made it a programming model
that people who are not doing databases
the systems could actually use and
naturally at Google there are people who
were doing web search information
retrieval data mining machine learning
all kinds of things and all of these
people could suddenly right very nice
large data parallel programs in this
abstraction I will tell you what that is
in a minute but what they did was really
the system took care of the
parallelization distributing it and most
importantly fault tolerance and because
of this it became very easy to use since
then of course a bunch of theory people
have started to look at you know what
other algorithms can be
build on this model for natural
interesting computational problems okay
so going back to the datastream model
that alone which is in Sega d
popularized here the input has n records
that arrive in some order and the
algorithm is restricted in three ways
number one you have read on success to
the stream you only read an element and
then it's gone you never see it again
second your internal memory is expected
to be really small poly log in this
stream length is considered good and
finally you would like to process each
element as soon as possible if a memory
is relatively small there's not a whole
lot you could do so poly log in also
makes sense then I already talked about
frequency moments there's a bunch of
other very nice algorithms heavy eaters
or finding elements that appear
unusually popularly in the stream for
some definition of that Jacob mirada
Christian and Patrick [ __ ] had this nice
paper on finding duplicates in a data
stream which is again a surprisingly
nice almost elementary algorithm that
actually works very nicely counting the
number of inversions in other words
you're given a stream of numbers and you
want to know how many pairs of numbers
are out of order with respect to each
other so for a whole bunch of these
problems there are very nice streaming
algorithms pretty much all of them are
log type poly log complexity the one
thing that that surprisingly week about
the data stream model is that it doesn't
seem very relevant to problems where the
input is something beyond just the
sequence of numbers or the output is
more than a sequence of numbers right if
your input is a graph when you want to
find the connected components it seems
very difficult to even think about it or
reason about it in the data stream model
matrices or linear programming problems
or machine learning questions which
typically involves some type of
optimization seem not very relevant or
seem hard to analyze the data stream
model certainly for upper bounds
the datastream model also has a very
natural connection to communication
complexity if you want to prove a lower
bound on the data stream complexity of a
problem you typically break up the input
into two or more parts and assume that
multiple players have pieces of the
input and you show one round or multi
round lower bounds in the communication
complexity initially whatever you if
there is a good data stream algorithm
Alice or Bob or Carol could take the
state of the algorithm and pass it on to
the next player have them continue the
simulation and you'll get a good
communication upper bone so a lower
bounded communication complexity usually
means that you get a space lower bound
on any data stream algorithm as I
mentioned earlier the memory requirement
makes up urban problems somewhat
unnatural you cannot even maintain a
connected component or a minimum
spanning tree or any of these things so
what typically ends up happening is even
the interesting algorithms tend to
compute the value of a solution right
you want to decide if a given graph in a
data stream model has a max cut of at
least some value or a min cut of at
least somewhere any of these things
right so you're not solving the right
problem the data stream model therefore
they did the ideas are usually very nice
but they tend not to be very applicable
in practice and similarly for the same
reason lower bounds in this mode will
often say something very nice about the
the structure of the problem the
combinatorial structure of the problem
then a then about our inability to solve
in practice because when people need to
solve connected components they build
something and solve connected components
right just because we proved our point
here doesn't mean that it never gets
solved so so that's the that's a weight
set of affairs that this leaves us in so
let's turn to MapReduce quickly here the
model is that the input is a bunch of
key value pairs you have a lots of them
typically this the large number of key
value pairs are assumed to be split into
chunks and stored on multiple machines
or multiple disks or whatever there are
three primitive functions primitive
functions Maps shuffle and reduce the
map or the mapper is a memory less
function that at any one time looks at a
single record a key value pair and it
produces zero or more intermediate key
value pairs again possibly with
different keys and it can produce many
different case in the same invocation
the fact that the mapper is a memory
less functional makes it particularly
attractive because you can start a whole
bunch of these mappers and a lot of
different machines each machine
processes a whole bunch of Records key
value pairs and you know they can all
happen in peril look like the whole
bunch of intermediate key value pairs
get generated and that is one of the
reasons why it's such a nice model to
build Kuhn and optimize there's massive
parallelism because of the memory
listeners you typically think of a
single record as a few few hundred or
few kilobytes at best and that that
works very nicely in the shuffle stage
all the intermediate key value pairs are
looked at and they're grouped by the key
and once the grouping is done they get
passed to the reducer which is again
another memoryless function it takes a
single key together with all its values
I put a star there because in in
practice it's often convenient to assume
that it gets hold of all the values in
some particular pre-specified order and
in fact often a reducer is implementing
a one pass or a data stream style
algorithm over all the values for that
one key because in some cases the number
of values for a single key could be so
large that it might be hard to load it
in memory and things get a bit bit
complicated but again the point here is
that the reducer is also a memory less
function which deals with one key and
all its values together and it produces
zero or more output values for that key
so which again this memory less this
property makes it very easy to to run a
lot of these reduces in parallel and
effectively what's happening is a whole
Orchestra of mappers and reducers are
running together with these shufflers
grouping and passing things around so
this is because of the simplicity of the
model it's very easy to write code in
this model and it's very very natural to
optimize the performance of the system
here that's a great fit for lots of
simple data processing tasks i put
simple in quotes because typically the
nature of the computation here is very
simple for example one of the original
motivations was building an inverted
index at
Google you have a lot of documents each
document has a lot of terms think of a
document coming with the key is the
document ID and the terms are all the
values for the document and what you
want to build from there is an inverted
index which is given a term you want to
collect a list of all the documents that
contain it and that's a very easy
straightforward MapReduce computation
that was in fact one of the motivating
examples of this the one thing about
MapReduce is that the IO complexities
rather large because of all the
intermediate values that get generated
and regrouped and rewritten as files
which means that we really should think
of each pass of MapReduce if you want to
solve a more complicated problem by
sequence of my producers you have to
assume that the past complexity is
fairly large the past complexity of
their own complexity is important
because the IO usually sauce slows
things down and if you want to run a
MapReduce with 100 or 200 passes almost
surely something's going to go wrong
when some machine is going to come down
and it is it is not considered a good
thing to write a MapReduce with square
root of n passes for an incised input
despite this of course there was a very
nice large-scale machine learning
platform at Google that was built based
on multiplayer map produced there is a
talk by tushar Chandra whose distributed
systems expert at this year's wisdom
conference it's worth looking at just to
understand what kind of issues underlay
large data set computations in a really
large real-world application the reason
I bring this up here is that the model
is simple model is nice the past
complexity is large but to build
something very general purpose based on
a model like this still took a lot of
work it took about five six years of
work before this machine learning system
could be widely applicable so our
assumption is about models often leave a
large gap between theory and practice
and I will come back to this little
later turning to more more theoretical
side of things this whole bunch of
clever algorithms that people have
designed for graph and optimization
problems in MapReduce are typically the
log or poly log many passes of MapReduce
algorithms some examples are minimum
spanning tree matching greedy algorithms
sub graphs and so on I'll talk about one
of the paradigms called the filtering
paradigm a little later but that's
actually a nice nice one to remember
what the filter in paradigm does is it
brings a nice combination of MapReduce
together with simple standard sequential
computation interleaving them nicely to
to produce some good results mentioned
it a little bit later so the sum up why
MapReduce has lifted in a slightly and
satisfied to state of affairs the Lord
Jo complexity meant that multiple passes
and multiple iterations to take time and
there is something called the patient's
threshold which is you have some idea
you want to build something and put it
into an experiment eight experiment and
see how it does typically takes you
wanted to take a few hours not a few
days right if something didn't go right
you have to your resetting the clock and
starting all over again and the past
complexity is often often a hindrance in
in getting things done much faster and
it again the second point is somewhat
orthogonal to this and that is the the
software ecosystem matters more and this
is the point I made earlier about the
machine learning system building the
software ecosystem around that turned
out to be as important as the quality of
the algorithm itself on the lower bound
side MapReduce is a big roadblock for us
because with the right number of passes
it's as powerful as the complexity class
NC so there's not much we can we can
really hope to improve in terms of past
lower bounds or the size of the
intermediate output or any of these
things so a passes you start with the
set of start with an input we write a
MapReduce computation other words you
write a mapper and reducer you run them
together you get a new set of new output
and then you repeat the same algorithm
on this a typical multipath MapReduce
algorithm does this over and over again
until the desired output is produced
think of it as rounds crumbs if you like
okay so here's what I want to tell you
about in the rest of the talk so let's
make a few comments about how in many
real problems there are two parameters
think of the graph with number of
vertices and edges it's really a bit of
a generalization of that I want to
highlight two theoretical models that
seem to be heading in the right
direction but this still leaves some
parameters that that need to be
understood better one is the semi
streaming model the other one is the
filtering MapReduce algorithms that I
alluded to earlier I also want to
introduce two models that practitioners
were very fond of these days the
parameter server and the mill wheel type
model again I've mentioned what they are
and i want to highlight connected
components is a simple problem where I
think there is a fundamental gap in our
understanding and I think it's worth
understanding it either in terms of a
better upper bond or in terms of a good
lower bond okay I already mentioned this
is like saying that in a real problem
we'll graph you have two parameters N
and M and it seems to matter that one is
much smaller than the other one and it
seems like n is something small that we
can deal with but very often even there
assuming that there is n words of main
memory is often not accurate you might
need to split it into multiple machines
if you want to do it in a unit random
access memory the parameter m often is
very large think of it as the number of
edges in a graph and there we are forced
to partition the input into multiple
files in disk and the notion of
streaming as we talked about in the
theory world is completely impractical
there's also the issue of density or the
degree of the instances think of it as
the number of variables that show up in
a typical constraint in a denier
programming problem so semi streaming
this was introduced by Moodle Krishna in
about two thousand three and the some of
the nicest papers here came from the
work of fraggin bomb sampath cannon
Andrew McGregor sage Sri and jonesing
that since 2004 and more recently on and
go have been writing a bunch of
interesting papers in be in this area as
well on graph and LP algorithms so here
the idea is very simple so the idea that
motivation proposes that
you get to do a single pass on on on the
input except that now instead of the
traditional poly log memory you assume
that you have n times poly log memory if
you think about a graph problem the
assumption is that you can hold
information a few bytes of information
per vertex but you cannot afford to hold
few bytes of information per edge that
you get a streaming pass over the edges
but you're you can you can hold a
non-trivial amount of information on a
per vertex basis one or a few passes
over the data is ok so this is the this
is the model and i'll tell you why this
is actually a nice model in a few
minutes but Feigenbaum it'll get some
graph algorithms in this model quite a
few interesting problems they sold more
recently gohan and on gave some LP
algorithms I think specifically packing
and covering problems in this model and
also maximum weighted matching I think
there's a very rare load bound here in a
paper of Ashish girl Michael capital of
and sanjeev khanna that appeared three
years ago and sewed up and this lower
bound is actually very interesting one
if you think about it this is a
communication lower bone so you have
Alice and Bob each have parts of a
subset of the edges of an input graph
and what they showed was if you wanted
us approximate the size of the maximum
bipartite matching in this graph to a
factor that's better than two-thirds you
need strictly super linear in n
communication so this is like this I
think roughly gets to the heart of the
story right because on the one hand this
is quite far from saying it's not set it
in terms of the number of edges it's
still in terms of number of vertices the
reason this is interesting is if you
think about the standard semi streaming
model of computation there are certain
problems that become very very easy for
example I'll mention this a bit later to
it graph connectivity becomes very easy
in this model right you can maintain a
union find tree in n n log in size
memory and you can do it in a single
pass that works pretty well whereas here
on the one hand you don't need to
transfer the entire deaf I think they in
fact get some algorithms to in this
paper but I'm not not totally sure but
something like n amount of memory or n
poly login amount of memory is not going
to work if you want to do it in this
wonderful communication model so that is
actually a tire and surprising lower
bondage in this world the other
algorithmic paradigm that has emerged
one of the nicer ones is this one called
MapReduce filters or the notion of
interleaving standard sequential
computations with MapReduce passes and
this is due to Sylvia lattanzi been
mostly sit Sri and Sergei vassal which
key here it's a it's a bit important to
pay attention to the parameters here
there are n vertices in a graph and m2 n
to the 1 plus C I just think of C as a
half so you have about end times square
root of and many edges in this graph and
you have a non-trivial number of
missions think of it as n to the point 1
or into the one quarter number of
machines and each one has again and are
non-trivial amount of memory more than
quadrant memory here but assume that
there is a gap between C and epsilon
here right so the what they do in this
modulus again I'll tell you the result
first and then we can go back here they
they produce algorithms where you have
so many missions with this kind of
parameters and the algorithms run in C
over epsilon many rounds penetrative
algorithm where typically what you do is
you do some basic competition that
MapReduce pass over the data or buy
produce or any of these simple kind of
parallelization primitives and once you
do that you do some computation in
memory and then you try to put things
together so again the problem size is
small they say okay let's go solid on a
single machine if not they're going to
partition the edges among machines and
that's something that's very easy to do
in a single MapReduce pass you are
saying some random number to every edge
and you distribute them according to the
random number and then the key notion
here is filtering out it just that you
think are not needed so once you once
the data gets partitioned among machines
each machine does the local computation
again think of minimum spanning tree
each machine gets a bunch of the edges
it looks at its edges computes an MST on
what it has and whatever edge it doesn't
need for the MST it throws away now the
remaining graph is really the union of
all these minimum spanning trees but now
that you get a significant data
reduction did and you iterate until
until the data becomes small enough that
you can fit in memory so that that
paradigm works nicely for minimum
spanning tree works for maximal
matchings it works for connected
components and by reducing approximate
maximum weight matching to maximal
matchings they also produce algorithms
for maximum weighted matching this model
so these are fairly simple fairly nice
algorithms and end it and in settings
like this where your machines have a
non-trivial amount of memory and you
have a non-trivial number of them you
get significant speed ups okay so that's
part 2 part 3 I want to mention couple
of things about what practitioners do
and I want to tie it all back together
with connected components in a couple of
minutes okay in practice there are two
models that I wanted to bring bring your
attention one is this thing called a
parameter server here think of again the
dichotomy between N and M here if n is
the number of parameters you want to
maintain again something a few kilobytes
per per vertex is ok that's something
that we can afford and this is managed
by by a distributed hash table that is
spread across multiple machines so even
for large values of n you can you can
actually do things fine one of the most
common use cases of this is in machine
learning where do you have a bunch of
parameters that you are optimizing over
bunch of variables that you are
optimizing over or think of a neural
network every weight in the neural
network is a parameter so you have a
whole bunch of them the most recent
neural networks often have several
millions of these edges several hundreds
of millions of these edges so that gets
split among multiple machines and it's a
very common it's becoming increasingly
popular in the machine learning
community both in the Google
deep machine learning style algorithms
also in other kinds of machine learning
systems that that people of people are
built so in the machine learning setting
what happens is typically there's a
bunch of parameters that you're
optimizing over and you want to make
sure that you find I find a solution
that's that's optimal or nearly optimal
and it's a function of these things and
the input training data gets split
across machines every mission processes
a whole bunch of training examples its
operating on its own noisy copy of the
of the global parameter set right every
now and then the Machine talks to the
parameter server and just give me the
most recent copy of the parameters let
me go and update the parameters locally
typically what you do is you run the
from the model your neural network on on
on on some training data if it makes a
mistake you say let me change the
parameters so that I get a little bit
better performance of the training gear
that I look at and after a while the
Machine communicates its updates to the
parameter server so at any point every
mission has some noisy copy of the
global information and they synchronize
periodically so so that's and all the
system optimizes for all the nice things
like checkpointing parameters and all
that organize things fault tolerance and
distributions and everything else is
hidden from the user so if you are
programming a machine learning model you
are actually pretending as if you get to
deal with the entire parameter space and
you are doing things nicely for my
machine learning problems there's also
some nice convergent step results at
least in some theoretical sense so it
works quite cool for them I'm going to
skip the comment about the
multiplicative updates so the other
model I want to mention is this thing
called millville again you can go look
it up it's fairly straightforward these
are two systems papers and systems work
here the assumption is that you do a lot
of message passing and we think of
information as split among lots of
machines and each machine manages a
bunch of information and the key idea
here is that there is a key value pair
and every machine is responsible for a
bunch of keys and instead of thinking
monolithically as order in global memory
we think of each key as getting order
one words of memory and lots of messages
get exchanged and computations happen
when one machine decides to Center
to another machine about updating some
information again the system's take care
of all kinds of nice things here okay so
I'll just say a few things about
connected components and come to my
punchline in the next slide connected
components is a problem that we all know
and love and we think it's easy from
many different viewpoints as I mentioned
the filtering algorithms work really
well here small number of rounds in the
in the in the model where machines have
a lot of memory and you have a good
number of machines there's also a lot of
there's also very nice MapReduce
friendly algorithm available for this
this is actually a very simple algorithm
that says again i'll skip the detail
that works nicely in log squared n
rounds and this also a nice semi
streaming algorithm the union-find
algorithm works in a single pass login
work / edge and log and amount of memory
but the big problem with all of this is
that the total amount of bits
communicated is omega m and that is one
of the biggest reasons why these kind of
despite all these nice things that that
is too much communication in practice
right we said that Omega M is a lot of
memory to keep but it also becomes the
bottle like when you when you want to
run MapReduce style computations for
this so that takes me to my final slide
which is really this which is the
message I wanted to leave you with pick
your favorite problem think of connected
components for example and I want to
propose this is a model of what
constitutes a scalable computation so
you have a large number of machines and
that's important that the scaling
happens at the large number of machines
not for two three four or a constant
number of machines allow yourself poly
log in n many thumbs significant amount
of memory per machine and poly log in
and what we want obviously is scaling so
we want them over K times poly log time
per machine so that's the point of
throwing a lot of machines here but the
key point i want to bring about is that
the total amount of data that gets
transferred either in the message
passing sense or again here you don't
think of blackboard or message sense if
you are not bring lower bolts for upper
bones either in terms of the data
written to disk or data communicated
between machines we want to reduce the
total data transfer to n log n or n poly
log and as a
us too having a dependence on em the
bigger parameter here or prove that it
cannot be done right pick your favorite
k player communication model we might as
well drop the time and memory
requirements because they usually played
no role in communication road bones so
can we show that in for large K we have
a lower bond we have a no-load bond that
is strictly faster-growing than n poly
log in so I think doing something like
this either in napa bones or lower
bounds if you get a great upper bound
wonderful go to the next problem pick a
harder problem like matching or
something or if not the point where we
prove first lower bound here would be I
consider a breakthrough right thank you
so any questions so I see is there any
place in movies where somebody is using
linear sketches oh that's a linear
sketches meaning the kind of AMS kind of
sketches I'm pretty sure that's the case
yeah sketches are indeed useful and
Linnaeus nearest neighbor type stuff
there are libraries and things that have
been built yeah there's also a nice
paper instock 2002 by Moses chart occur
that also introduces some kind of
sketching those are inspired by the max
cat algorithm so it's not a linear
sketch really but yeah that kind of
sketching is also quite commonly used
that's the expected value you know
anything about the distribution I
produced I thought what adds to the
complexity of analyzing the system is
because multiple people are running
multiple tasks right and so that maybe
there are more times the interaction
between all these things works quite
well and so the system does though all
the things that you want you to do
because maybe you're stressing one part
of the system that is another thing
stressing another part of the system so
is there any value to analyzing even
individual i see i see this question is
the value of mobility is one of the
reasons it's valuable is because there's
lots of people turning lots of
computations and it deals with the the
ensemble of all the computations very
well and that is certainly true from
systems perspective so you are asking
the question why even bother analyzing a
single algorithm in the MapReduce model
I think our notion of what is efficient
keeps getting refined right mmmm I
reason at least is that steaming
algorithms are not practical in the
sense that we think about them right so
other than my produces something that
people can go and write code for people
do write code for that too okay so let's
thank the speaker again